>> Greg: HELLO.
WOKESTERS RENAME A WIZARDS GAME.
WERE J.K. ROWLING'S TWEETS TO
BLAME FOR A FAKE SPORT CHANGING
ITS NAME?
I SPEAK OF QUIDDITCH.
THE FAKE SPORT MADE POPULAR BY
THE HARRY POTTER SERIES BUT ALSO
MY NICKNAME WHEN I GARDEN
TOPLESS.
THE GAME HAS BEEN BROUGHT TO
REAL LIFE BY COLLEGE NERDS WITH
NO GIRLFRIENDS BEFORE THEY
BECOME COMEDIANS.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MANAGE
QUIDDITCH ARE CHANGING THE NAME
TO QUAD BALL IN PART TO THE
SIMPSON THEMSELVES FROM J.K.
ROWLING AND HER SO-CALLED
ANTI-TRANS COMMENTS.
IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC PEOPLE
ERASING WOMEN ADDED A BALL TO
THE NAMED.
THE NAME OF QUIDDITCH AND ITS
RELATIONSHIP TO J.K. ROWLING
CARRIES A STIGMA THAT NO LONGER
ALIGNS WITH THE MISSIONS AND
VALUES OF THE INTERNATIONAL
QUIDDITCH ASSOCIATION.
IT'S FUNNY.
HOPEFULLY THESE YOUNG FOLKS CAN
ALSO MOVE PAST THE STIGMA OF
STILL BEING VIRGINS.
ROWLING HAS TAKEN ISSUES WITH
ISSUES.
DEFENDING THE CONCEPT OF
BIOLOGICAL SEX.
THE INTERNATIONAL QUIDDITCH
ASSOCIATION, U.S. QUIDDITCH AND
MAJORLY QUIDDITCH DITCHED THE
OLD NAME BECAUSE WARNER BROS.
HOLDS THE TRADEMARK.
BEFORE YOU GET UPSET, REMEMBER
NONE OF THIS IS REAL.
LIKE THE NOTION THAT MEN CAN
HAVE BABIES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, NEW SPORTS ARE
INVENTED ALL THE TIME.
>> HEY, CHARLIE.
ME AND THE GUYS INVENTED THIS
AWESOME NEW SPORT AND WE ARE
STARTING A LEAGUE.
>> CAN I JOIN?
WHAT'S IT CALLED?
>> SUCKER PUNCH.
>> WELCOME TO THE TEAM.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE BEEN A LARGE
FINANCIAL SUPPORTER OF THE TRANS
COMMUNITY.
>> Rob: I HAVE.
I PUT MANY TRANS WOMEN THROUGH
COLLEGE.
>> Greg: I JUST WANTED TO ASK
THAT QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS FAIR?
DOES IT MAKE ANY SENSE?
>> Rob: IS A BIG FAN OF THIS
BOARD, I'VE BEEN LOBBYING FOR A
LONG TIME.
THE SHOULD CHANGE THE NAME TO
"THIS GAME SUCKS."
QUAD BALL SOUNDS LIKE A GROIN
INJURY YOU GET PLAIN QUIDDITCH.
IT IS MORE LANGUAGE NONSENSE.
IT'S LIKE CHANGING THE NAME
BASEBALL BECAUSE TY COBB SHARPEN
HIS SPIKES AND DROVE THEM INTO
PEOPLE.
IT'S DUMB.
>> Greg: DANA, THEY WON'T LET
GO OF J.K. ROWLING.
ISN'T IT KIND OF AMAZING?
>> Dana: .
IMAGINE SAYING I CAME UP WITH
THE STUPID GAME IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
YOU CAN'T QUIT ME.
I QUIT YOU IS WHAT SHE WOULD
PROBABLY SAY.
I LIKE TO DO RESEARCH FOR THE
SHOW.
EVERYONE, DO NOT GOOGLE
QUAD BALL.
OKAY?
>> Jim: WHAT SHE REALLY MEANS
IS GO GOOGLE QUAD BALL RIGHT
NOW.
>> Dana: .
DON'T DO IT.
>> Jim: I WANT TO GOOGLE IT.
>> Greg: I AM LOOKING AT
DURING THE BREAK.
I DON'T HAVE TO GOOGLE IT.
I JUST LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
KAT, DO YOU HAVE THE ATHLETIC
SKILLS TO EXCEL AT QUIDDITCH?
>> Kat: NO.
I ALSO WASN'T ALLOWED TO READ OR
WATCH HARRY POTTER BECAUSE MY
MOM SAID IT WAS EVIL.
IT'S TRUE.
BE CAREFUL.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY WANT
TO CHANGE THE NAME BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM
HARRY POTTER.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES FROM HARRY POTTER
LESS THIN PEOPLE WHO PLAYED
QUIDDITCH.
THEY NEED TO.
THEY SEEM LIKE PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY
CANNOT.
WHO IS THIS FOR?
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
RULES.
I NEVER LEARNED.
THIS IS SOMETHING I REFUSED TO
LEARN ABOUT.
THEY THINK J.K. ROWLING HAS
DISTURBING ATTITUDES ABOUT
TRANS, WHAT DID THEY THINK ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO INVENTED SOCCER?
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
BE PRO-TRANS.
PEOPLE WHO INVENTED ANY SPORT.
>> Rob: PROBABLY NOT FOR YOU
SAID J.K. ROWLING SAID FU, F YOU
TO THAT LETTER A FEW POWER
THAT'S HOW MUCH MONEY SHE HAS.
PEOPLE HAVE TO REALIZE SHE IS
THE FIRST WOMAN WHO ACTUALLY PUT
HERSELF ON THE LINE TO SPEAK UP
FOR BIOLOGICAL SEX.
UNLIKE A LOT OF THE OTHER ONES,
THE MACY GRAY FIASCO A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, J.K. ROWLING HAS
NEVER EVER EVER BACKED DOWN AND
SHE NEVER WILL BACK DOWN.
THIS IS THE HILL SHE IS DYING
ON.
IT'S ONLY PEOPLE SHE MADE
FAMOUS, THE HARRY POTTER KIDS
THE DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM
HER.
THE PEOPLE WHO CREATE THIS WORLD
OUT OF SOMETHING SHE CREATED,
THEY ARE DISTANCING THEMSELVES.
MORE POWER TO HER FOR NOT
BACKING DOWN.
>> Greg: THIS WOULD BE A GOOD
MONOLOGUE.
IT'S WEIRD HOW THE RISK RATIO OR
WHATEVER YOU CALL IT HAS
FLIPPED.
OLDER PEOPLE ARE MORE WILLING TO
TAKE RISKS.
YOUNGER PEOPLE HAVE TURNED INTO
THESE WEIRD PURITANS.
LIKE JOHN CLEESE.
TALKING ABOUT COMEDY.
ALL OF THESE OLDER COMEDIANS ARE
SAYING THE SAME THING.
WHAT IS WRONG?
>> Jim: WHERE'S THE LOYALTY?
ALL THESE PEOPLE.
SHE MADE YOU A STAR.
I'M PINCHING MY WAY INTO YOU, SO
WHATEVER YOU SAY GOES.
YOU CAN NEVER LOSE ME.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU STAND FOR
AND WHAT RALLIES YOU GO FOR.
TEAM GUTFELD ALL THE WAY.
>> Greg: I HAVE AN ALLY.
WE HAVE TO MOVE ON.
COMING UP